[Music]
Noora is supposed to cross a bridge to
reach the other side sounds easy right
but it isn't because the bridge is
heavily guarded but she knows that the
guards work in shifts and at night there
are exactly 17 minutes for which the
gods do not keep a watch on the bridge
so if she has to cross the bridge it has
to be within those 17 minutes now Nora
takes only a minute to cross the bridge
and she could have easily crossed within
that timeframe if she was alone but
along with her she needs to take her
grandfather who takes 10 minutes to
cross the bridge her father who takes 5
minutes and her sister who takes 2
minutes to cross the bridge can all four
of them cross the bridge together
absolutely not the bridge is strong
enough to hold a maximum of two people
at a time and there is another twist
here when the guards are not keeping a
watch the lights are switched off and it
turns completely dark and Nora and her
family have just one Lantern with them
so how do they all cross the bridge
before the guards turn up can Nora help
the entire family cross the bridge
within 17 minutes before we move on to
the solution let's look at the clues the
first three clues are pretty easy to
understand what does the fourth clue
tell us it says that there's just one
Lantern that thay has how did you
interpret this it tells us that if two
people cross the bridge and reach the
other side then one person needs to come
back with the lantern because if the
Lantern doesn't reach the start point
again nobody can cross the bridge
because of the darkness I have another
question for you when two people cross a
bridge what's the time that will be
considered say for instance Nora and her
Father together cross the bridge how
long would they take to cross it what do
you think here we make a basic
analogical assumption that people cannot
increase their speed but they can walk
slower if need be so Nora will walk
slower to accompany her grandpa
throughout and the time taken by both of
them to cross the bridge will be 10
minutes which is the slower person's
time taken so when two people cross the
bridge the total time taken will be the
time taken by the slower person okay now
that we've understood the clues how do
we approach this problem if we were in
Nora's place
let's see we came up with a plan where
we decide to send the elders safely
first so G and s crossed the bridge
first they would take ten minutes to
cross the bridge what would be the next
step n and s are yet to reach the other
side can we just let them cross the
bridge no we can't because they don't
have a lantern so either G or F would
need to come back with the lantern we
can't send G back because he would take
10 more minutes and the total time
elapsed would cross 17 minutes so what
if we sent s back F will take 5 minutes
to cross the bridge and reach the
starting point with this 15 minutes have
already elapsed with just 2 minutes left
we have three people left near the
starting point it's impossible to get
everyone to the finish point with the
time limit right even though this
doesn't work it tells us something
important it tells us that G and F
cannot be the first ones to cross the
bridge together
also we know that one person needs to
come back with the lantern so to save
time we should make sure that the
fastest or the second fastest ones
should be the ones to come back with the
lantern and/or s are the better choices
to come back as compared to s or G so
what do we do now take a moment and
think maybe we can come up with an
alternative option where the slowest
person of the family is made to go with
the fastest person so if N and G go
together the time they will take to
cross the bridge is 10 minutes this
leaves them with 7 minutes now when Nora
comes back with a lantern only 6 minutes
will be left can n s and F cross the
bridge in 6 minutes given the conditions
not
but this tells us that s and G has to
travel together to save time if they
travel separately they will lose 15
minutes for sure and we also know that F
and G cannot be the first ones to cross
the bridge together so is there any plan
the family can come up with to cross the
bridge together before the guards take
their position we know Nora is a smart
and witty girl even with the time limit
she manages to help her family
cross the bridge so how did she go about
it first
Nora decided that the fastest two of the
family members would cross the bridge
Sonora takes her sister along as Nora's
sister takes two minutes to cross the
bridge the total time taken would be 2
minutes 15 minutes more to go what next
well 1 between them will need to come
back with the lantern so whom shall we
choose we would select Nora
because she's the fastest Nora takes a
minute to come back with the lantern to
the other end of the bridge 14 minutes
remain
what next we'd seen that F and G have to
travel together in order to utilize the
time at hand
hence the only practical solution Nora
comes up with is to hand over the
lantern to her father and asks him to
take her grandfather along the two of
them crossed the bridge in ten minutes
but now the family members only have
four minutes left now someone has to
come back with the lantern to get Nora
to the other side whom would you choose
f G or s it's very clear now that F and
G cannot take up this responsibility due
to time constraints hence Nora's sister
takes up this task and crosses the
bridge towards Nora with the lantern
that'll take two more minutes
now after her journey across the bridge
they are left with just two minutes and
now both of them cross the bridge
together the total time they will take
to cross the bridge is two minutes that
makes the total of 17 minutes the guards
are back at their position while Nora
and her family crossed the bridge
unnoticed wasn't this interesting is
there any other strategy that Nora could
have applied to cross the bridge please
share your ideas in the comment section
and don't forget to share this video
with your friends and family now let me
leave you with a follower problem
imagine you were at the starting point
of the bridge with your family you can
cross the bridge in two minutes while
your sister takes double the time that
you take to cross the bridge your father
takes 5 minutes to cross the bridge
while your grandfather takes 4 times the
time you take to cross the bridge in
this case can you tell me the minimum
amount of time you would require to
cross the bridge assuming the other
conditions are the same leave your
answers in the comment section the
strategy you would use for this one may
not be the same as we used for the
previous one all the best
[Music]